RAJ AJRAWAT: My
name is Raj Ajrawat.
I'm a product specialist
here at Google
for the Android platform.
And today, I'll be sharing
with you some key updates
from the Android
Instant Apps team,
including a lot of
the efforts that we're
doing to scale the
product as well as sharing
details and best practices
and key learnings
from a lot of our partners who
have launched Instant Apps.
At the end, I'll
introduce Jean on stage,
and we'll have them talk
about a lot of the work
that they did to actually
get their instant app up
and running.
And hopefully we can learn
from what they did as well.
So let's start by actually
reviewing a lot of the work
that our team has done
up until this point.
As I'm sure you all know,
Android Instant Apps
officially launched back
at Google IO in May.
Any developer can now
build an instant app
and publish that instant
app to the Play Store.
And what's been
really exciting for me
is to actually
see apps in places
that they really
weren't ever in before.
You can see things
like previously,
the Play Store
was the gatekeeper
to all the traffic
and engagement
that you had as a developer.
Or you had to configure
very complex deep links
to get users inside
your native experience.
But users are now
actually accessing
your native
experience across all
of these different
services, from Google search
to email and messaging,
and even from Twitter.
I'm also really happy to
announce that we've now
enabled over 800 million
devices globally for Instant
Apps, which is actually well
over the 500 million devices
that we enabled only
just eight weeks ago.
So we're actually accelerating
a lot of the Instant App usage
that users are able to access,
and we're really working hard
to make sure that users are able
to experience these Instant App
experiences.
Now, looking at all
of these new services
to drive users into
your Instant App,
we asked ourselves
what could we be
doing on Play to actually
help drive your users
to those experiences.
That's why I'm really happy to
announce the Try Now button.
For Instant Apps that
have a default URL,
users will be able to
navigate to your Instant app
from your Play Store listing.
Here you can see the Try
Now button for Skyscanner.
When a user taps on
the Try Now button,
they are taken to the
Skyscanner Instant App.
Users are still able to
install your full app.
Nothing is going to
change with that.
And in fact, we're
seeing that we're not
seeing any cannibalization
from that experience, either.
We're really excited about
this initial bit of results.
This is still in
experimentation,
but it should be rolling
out, hopefully, very soon.
The other piece that I
want to talk about, too,
on the platform side
is that we're also
making it really easy for
users to engage and discover
these Instant App experiences
from Android, which
is why we've integrated
on the Launcher,
and we're also
adding the feature
to pin your Instant App to home.
The idea behind this is
to basically give users
more abilities to interact with
your Instant App experience
and ensure that
users are actually
able to experience these
across all these new surfaces.
This is rolling out as
part of the latest O
update that's going to be
happening in the next month
or so.
So by the end of
the year, we expect
users to actually be able
to access this on O devices.
Now, in order to make all
these features work for you,
you'll need to set up what we
call a canonical landing page.
This ensures that when
users come to your Instant
App via a button like Try
Now or through the launcher
integration that I just
showed you on the screen,
they'll have, essentially,
like a home screen experience.
Previously, when users would
tap on your Instant App,
they'd tap on a deep
link, and then they're
taken to a very
particular moment,
such as watching a video
or booking a restaurant.
But with this
default URL, they're
now able to access a home screen
experience on your Instant App.
Skyscanner, One
Football, Red Bull TV--
all of these apps have
canonical landing pages,
and it's really easy to
set up in the manifest.
And we encourage all of you,
as you're building your Instant
App, to set up a
default URL to take
advantage of these new
services that are coming up.
So the team and I are
very happy with a lot
of the progress
that we are seeing
and the scale we've
achieved with the product.
But I'm going to shift gears a
little bit and talk about some
of the best practices
and key learnings
from many of the partners
that we're seeing who are
live within Instant Apps today.
We've talked to hundreds of
developers around the world.
And I've been involved in a
lot of those conversations,
so I can say it's definitely
been a lot of developer
conversations.
And in many cases,
the first conversation
that we always have is all
about what is your use case.
What do you want a
user to do when they're
in your native experience
now that they don't have
to actually install your app?
Do you want to increase the
conversion on your shopping
cart?
Do you want to get people
to watch more videos?
Jet was able to actually
increase their conversions
by 27%, and Vimeo
saw 130% increase
in engagement with their
videos just by having users
drive into their Instant App.
Understanding your use case
and what you want to achieve
is critical to understanding
the kinds of user journeys
that you want to create for
your Instant App experience.
I'm also happy to see that
developers are actually
building new
Android apps and are
thinking about Instant
Apps from day one.
The concept of modularizing
your code is not something new.
Everyone in the audience has
been thinking about that.
But as Instant Apps become
more embedded in the Android
platform, it's
imperative to think
about modularization
and Instant Apps
as one before you
start building.
Hit List up here had
modularization and Instant Apps
in mind when they started
Android development only eight
weeks ago.
As a result, they had a working
prototype of their Instant App
experience in under six weeks.
And we expect them
to actually get
to full launch in
the next two weeks.
Now, a key portion
of the work involved
in building your
Instant App is actually
building the modules for each
of the Instant App experiences.
I'm happy to announce,
as part of the latest SDK
release, which just
went out a week ago,
we've recently enabled
configuration APKs as well as
launching a shared
library support in Q4.
Now, configuration APKs
separate APK resources
for pictures,
strings, layout files
based on device architecture,
language, and screen density.
That allows you to generate
config splits according
to your specific needs,
ensuring users only get
a single set of resources
for any single Instant App
experience.
For example, if the APK has
English, French, Spanish,
and Italian resources
inside, and the end user
is using a Spanish
device, Play is only
going to deliver the
Spanish resources
to that particular user, saving
you space on your actual module
that you can use for your own
experiences and for your code.
Additionally, in speaking
to a lot of partners
live with Instant
Apps, they found
that there was a lot of
low-hanging fruit in terms
of simple optimizations
for reducing
APK size, such as removing
unused assets that were simply
not needed for their Instant App
as well as compressing pictures
using technologies like WebP.
Many partners viewed
the refactoring work
as a part of a larger
[INAUDIBLE] exercise
and were able to rework their
code base with a modular code
structure in mind.
Last, our team is
actually in the process
of testing shared
library support,
and we expect that
to go live in Q4.
The idea here is to help
with module size limits
by allowing you
to reuse code that
would be helpful
for shared resources
across your different
Instant App experiences.
The idea here is for us to
help reduce latency for the end
user, but also make sure
that you have plenty
of available space to stay
within the module size limit
to deliver whatever
experience you
want to have for your users.
Now, we're really
bullish on Instant Apps
because we're excited about all
the new user interactions that
are actually coming
up that this has
enabled for you as partners.
We're starting to see a few
key UX considerations emerge
as we've talked to partners
who have gone live with Instant
Apps, and we want to make
sure that we share those best
practices with you guys.
Now, a lot of our partners are
reconsidering their success
metrics.
As an industry and
as an ecosystem,
for the past nine years,
we've been simply talking
about installs constantly.
That's not to say that
we're going to change that.
But remember now that as
you remove the install, ask
yourself, what do I really
want the user to achieve
post-install?
Do I want them to buy a ticket?
Do I want them to
book a restaurant?
Do I want them to send a
message, watch a video?
You have the user
captured at that moment.
So look at that KPI as
your biggest metric now.
Partners who have been
able to use the same code
base in a project are
also seeing benefits
in terms of code maintenance.
A lot of our early
partners actually
built a separate code base
specifically for Instant Apps
just to get their
feet wet, just to see
what the experience was like.
But actually, a lot of
them have moved over
to reusing a lot
of the same code
that they have in their
fully-installed experience
in order to make sure that
their code is in sync and also
their user experiences
are in sync.
Some of the best
partner experiences
ensure that they don't
interfere with task completion.
Now, this is a really
big one because you
have to remember when
a user taps on a URL,
they're not asking
themselves, am I
going to a native experience
or an installed app
or a mobile web experience.
They just want to
send a message.
book a restaurant.
They just want to watch a video.
So the last thing
you'd want to do
is to interrupt that
flow for the user
by asking them to log in to
your app, or create an account,
or go through some
sort of tutorial.
You never want to actually
break a user flow post-install.
And you'll find a
lot of better results
once you allow the user to
complete a full journey.
And last, remember to maintain
the user state from Instant App
into the installed app.
There are some updates
in the latest SDK where
we allow you to
actually carry over
a lot more detail
from your Instant App
into the installed app.
So you can imagine, as a user
is interacting with your Instant
App, you're actually able
to take a lot of the data
that you gathered from there--
Raj watched a
certain video, or he
made a certain message, or
something along those lines--
and then provide me
with a warm install
once I actually install the app.
Cool.
Sorry.
All right.
So all of the items that I
pointed out on the last slide
are aimed at simply
reducing friction on mobile.
We set about building Android
Instant Apps because we
felt the friction
from installing
an app was simply unnecessary.
In a similar vein,
we provide tools
like Smart Lock for passwords as
well as the new Google Payment
API to reduce friction
on authentication as well
as on payments.
Now I'd like to invite Jean from
LaFourchette up to the stage
to talk about his experiences
with building an Instant app.
Please join me in
welcoming Jean.
[APPLAUSE]
JEAN OKECKI: Hi.
I'm very happy to be here.
My name is Jean.
I'm responsible for the
apps at LaFourchette.
LaFourchette is a
restaurant booking company.
We are present in 11 countries,
mostly across Europe.
And as a company,
our goal is pretty
simple-- it's connecting
the right restaurant
to the right customer
at the right time.
So in other words, it's
reducing that friction
that you may have when
booking restaurants.
We're reducing
that friction which
is calling the restaurant,
waiting for it to be opened,
waiting for someone
to answer, and then
having to talk to someone who's
busy answering other clients.
So you'd be really
surprised to know
how many people still call
the restaurants to book
a reservation.
And we thought Instant
App was a good way
of reducing that friction.
So the use case--
Raj made it very clear.
It's very important to
rightly select your use case.
And for us, our key success
metric is the booking.
This is basically
how we are evaluated,
and this is, in the
end, how we make money.
So when we make
product decisions,
we always optimize for bookings.
So when we looked
at Instant Apps,
we looked at our
mobile web traffic.
And when you look at this
data, what you find out
is that a huge majority of
our traffic comes from Google
and comes from
people who directly
type the name of a
restaurant in Google.
So we recognize that,
for this group of users,
they already know the
name of the restaurants.
They know the number of
people that will go there.
They know the date.
They know the hour, et cetera.
So we don't want
them to download
the app to sign
up for an account,
to search the restaurant again.
That's way too much of a
hassle for a first experience
with our brand.
So in this context,
Instant Apps allowed
us to allow the user to
perform the action directly.
He just searches for the
restaurant, makes the booking,
and it's done.
It was really an opportunity to
improve our key metric again ,
which is the bookings.
How did it go?
So back in March, when we joined
the Instant App Early Access
program, Google
asked us one thing,
which was to be ready
before Google I/O.
And that left us
with three weeks.
That's really not a
lot for two reasons,
and those were our
two big challenges
that ended up as opportunities.
The first one is the
legacy code of our app.
Especially for the booking
flow, it was full legacy.
And as you know, Instant App are
all about modular architecture,
modular code, which means
that the feature should
be able to run independently.
That was pretty scary.
But in the end, it
was rather fast.
We decided to
start from scratch,
and we developed
the booking process.
And in less than two
weeks, that was done.
Also, because we started
modularizing our app,
we found out all of the
advantages that proved to us.
And now every new feature
that we are developing
is based on this new
modular architecture, which
means that turning those
features into Instant App
is very, very quick, and
it's almost painless.
So if your features
are already modular,
this wouldn't cost you much.
And if they're not, it's
really an opportunity
to modularize your code.
The second challenge
was the size.
So your Instant App shouldn't
be more than four megabytes.
And in those four megabytes,
you have shared resources which
are not directly your feature.
So we had to find ways to reduce
the size of our Instant App.
The first thing we did was to
access the libraries we had.
For instance, we found
out that Fresco was
a library that was way too big.
It was almost as big as
the Instant app itself.
So we removed it.
We removed this one, and we
replaced it by another one.
And our main app now
benefits from those changes.
In terms of designs,
we couldn't,
with this four-megabyte limit,
have PNGs for design assets.
So we moved to fully
vectorial assets.
We asked our design team
to provide us with those.
And now this is
something we still
do right now for
our new features,
and our app benefits from it.
Results-- because the experience
is better with an Instant App,
we see a better conversion rate.
And that's, once
again, key for us.
Booking is our key metric.
So when we have an increase
in compression rate,
this means we get more money.
Also, we found out that
this allowed us to open
our experience to new users.
Because we-- usually,
have about 10%
of users who book
from a restaurant
that is not in
their own country,
because we made the
brand available to people
who don't know our brand, we now
have this share reaching 30%.
So it's a good way of reaching
customers who otherwise
wouldn't go too LaFourchette.
What's next?
The first thing we'll do
is optimize the user flow.
We'll try to reduce
the number of steps.
Then one key thing
we'd like to make
is develop the restaurant
page as an Instant App.
As you understood,
we try to leverage
the huge volume of traffic
that comes from Google.
And most of this traffic
is on the restaurant page
because people type directly
the restaurant name.
So when we'll manage
to have this restaurant
page modularized and
available on Instant App,
we'll be able to offer a full
experience, native experience
to users without
app installation,
search for a restaurant
name in Google,
land on the native
restaurant page
with a video and a
native map, and then go
to the native booking flow.
And then we'd like to
implement canonical page that
were just announced and
leverage the icon launcher that
will be available on Android O.
So in the end, Instant
App brought us two things.
The first thing is incremental
traffic and bookings,
and the second thing
is that it brought us
a [INAUDIBLE] of our code
base, which was a good thing.
Thank you, and back to you, Raj.
[APPLAUSE]
RAJ AJRAWAT: Thank you, Jean.
Cool.
So it's great to see
what they've accomplished
in such a short amount of time.
And I'd like to leave you with
three key things to remember.
Instant Apps is about
discovery and engagement,
not just reducing
friction on mobile.
Remember that this
somewhat represents
a paradigm shift in how we've
been thinking about apps so
far.
Because while we
remove the install,
we're now asking you
to think about what
do you want to drive the
user to do once they're
in your native experience.
We're here to help you with
development and design,
and we recognize that this
work can be pretty heavy.
But we're hoping
that you can see
that the benefits for your
code base are very clear
and can also affect your
bottom line as well.
And we're deeply embedding
Instant Apps across both the OS
and the platform,
from the launcher
to Pin to Home to other
features that we're
working on currently.
And we're really
excited for what's
in store for Instant
Apps going forward.